did you ask civil servants last year to
arrange a one-on-one driving awareness
course when you were caught for speeding
it's pretty yes or no question well
first and foremost I'm focused on the
priorities for the British people as
Home Secretary that's cutting serious
crime with more police officers that's
standing up for victims of child sexual
abuse it's about stopping the boats and
I'm not going to take a backwards step
from working on those issues in relation
to your question last summer I was
speeding I regret that I paid the fine
and I took the points but we're focused
now on delivering for the British people
and working for them did you ask civil
servants to put you on a one-on-one
speed increase in relation to the
process I'm focused on delivering for
the British people do my job safely then
what I will say is that in my view I'm
confident that nothing Untold has
happened